now looking at the code we just wrote
what we really want to do is change this
from querying the value of key W to move
up which is the actual game information
we care about in order to do that we
need to bind keys to events in our game
engine like so in order to enable this
functionality where you're going to need
to do is modify the input manager class
just a tad bit firstly what you'll need
to do is actually add a bind function
now the bind function will need to take
the key value and attach it to the
action via the bindings dictionary value
that we've placed up here secondly
you'll actually have to modify your on
keydown and keyup events such that the
key code actually modifies the state in
the array now we've left these two
functions as exercises for you to figure
out good luck